he is the first broadcaster to call
play-by-play on boxing kickboxing MMA
and professional wrestling events on
national television he's been part of
Showtime for 11 years now and Showtime
will be the home of a wonderful
documentary that you need to all check
out on Friday May 25th because it is raw
it is honest and it is something that is
required viewing because bipolar
affective disorder is a condition that
afflicts nearly 5 percent of the u.s.
population please to have here certainly
on Mental Health Awareness Month in May
the bipolar rock and roller himself
Mauro Ranallo good to see you sir good
to see you rich and thank you very much
for giving me this platform I've been a
big time fan and I appreciate the glass
the Grace and the expertise in which you
do your job I appreciate you saying that
you said that all fair and I said please
say it wasn't serious
I really wasn't serious but you did miss
out one part but that's ok it's for the
sequel well we just showed a clip of
this documentary that I guess is a full
accounting of what you have been
battling for your entire life right
close yeah and you said it was tough for
you to watch so why do this documentary
why put your battle with bipolar
affective disorder on the screen for
everybody to see because it is tough to
watch but it is something necessary
mental health affects all of us in one
way or another you gave out a statistic
around the world globally depression one
of the leading causes of death and
because it's perceived as an invisible
illness I'm not in a wheelchair I'm not
on crutches I don't take insulin for
diabetes I'm not undergoing chemotherapy
for cancer rich but something equally is
debilitating impacts me and millions of
others and the fact that I'm a survivor
and the fact that I'm I'm here at the
highest level of my career being able to
be a fully functioning human being but
still dealing with what I deal with on a
daily basis I've lost more than one
person to suicide due to mental health
and the reason they killed themselves
was because they were ashamed
because they were shamed because society
and a lot of people employers and family
members even because they don't
understand they tend to ostracize and
ignore I've been very fortunate
throughout my life not only with family
but my employers I remember my first
full-time radio job I was 21 years old I
just been diagnosed and what triggered
my diagnosis because it usually is an
intense full stressful situation that
does was the death of my best friend
Michael Jansen in 19 we were thick as
thieves he died of a heart attack and so
I tried to pick up the pieces I was at
in radio full-time 21 years old within
months I'm already hospitalized again I
wrote a resignation letter to the radio
station my father refused to send it
because he knew how much broadcasting
and I'm being an announcer it meant to
me all my life my boss there Brian Laver
in Chilliwack British Columbia 1991 this
was he refused to let me go and and so
right from there they they showed
support they said hey this guy's
battling something but he's he's a hard
worker he's got robbed potential he's a
talented kid let's give him a chance and
I've had that support throughout my life
unfortunately millions of people do not
so for me I wanted it to be
uncomfortable I wanted it to be raw I
wanted to show me at my worst because
everyone sees me at my best and they
think wow what a life yeah I'm living
the dream much like yourself rich I'm so
blessed to be able to do what I do for a
living but for many people they are they
are alone they are scared and especially
men rich and we deal with it in sports
the alpha male and what's happening even
in the NFL and what's happened in the
NHL with so many enforcers killing
themselves we're having a conversation
on rich you talk to athletes you talked
to so many celebrities we always hey how
are you doing we really need to ask how
are you doing and then sit down and
listen and have that conversation
because so many people are not doing
well yes opposed to just being a throw
away yes in line and it's not snap out
of it or or you're you're just looking
for attention or it's amazing the amount
because you don't see it what you in
what you interpret don't be judgmental
just listen Mauro Ranallo here on the
Rich Eisen show and you know Kevin Love
writing about his pennies tax really was
jarring for a lot of people because
again you you see what he does for a
living it's a dream for many to even
attempt it let alone have it happen and
somebody who's got a ring and he's got a
life and he's got Bank doesn't matter it
doesn't matter and it was really jarring
what did you think of oh I am amazed in
timing is everything and let's face it
this this documentary is being released
by design during mental health awareness
month but even at this time of life we
have demar derozan
Kevin Love and the entire NBA God
blessed with their mind check the NHL
it's getting a little more involved with
riot Kerry just on People magazine with
her bipolar disorder Demi Lovato hip-hop
artists like logic rich you it's brandon
marshall brandon marshall
it's now and it has to happen it's it's
if you could simply save a life by
allowing but this is why this is my
therapy even talking to you i feel
better releasing it i wake up every
morning anxiety-ridden wondering is this
today i'm gonna be exposed as a fraud is
this the day i i lose everything so
talking talk therapy is so paramount and
and that's why much bigger people than
myself including the ones we mentioned
everyone needs to start talking about
and i love the fact that even Hollywood
finally with Claire Danes on on homeland
on Showtime Ron Howard with a beautiful
mind with Russell Crowe may have been
the first time that I saw mental health
the the the illness depicted in such an
artistic and yet respectful fashion look
at One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest which
is an amazing movie but look how we
treated people who are mentally ill
right look how we continue to treat them
rich I've been hospitalized once in
America I can afford the best treatment
I've never been in jail rich I would
challenge anyone to tell me where I was
in this treatment center for mental
health if it was any worse than jail in
terms of the treatment and the
conditions and then also the latest on
Robin Williams and his past a huge Idol
of what was going on in his amaze reign
at the time of his undoing and it's just
it is it's it's heartbreaking do you
feel Morrow
just seeing yourself in this documentary
way back in the day with wrestling and
having just heard you with the the fight
if you will of this century with
Mayweather and and Conor McGregor that
this is also your therapy when you sit
in front of a microphone that it is my
therapy since day one rich raps I it's
weird right because most people say
public speaking or being in front of
cameras the most fearful thing in
question and I don't know why but for me
since I was a kid I have all this is
when I feel alive this is when I can
work out everything and I know for many
people my god that guys over the top or
he's too energetic he's always yelling
and he's always coming up with these
weird pop-culture references or whatever
have back to me is my creative outlet
and that to me is is how I perform and
there is a benefit believe it or not and
you mentioned Robin Williams some of the
most brilliant minds some of the most
artistically gifted people and I'm not
putting myself in this category by any
stretch of the imagination but you have
well I mean there's a question it's but
that's well thank you but I'm saying so
what if we celebrated mental health you
know there's Coachella this amazing a
music festival with it how about if we
celebrate you know music comedy art and
instead of stigmatizing them celebrate
them because I had some of the most
empathetic people I know suffer from
mental health and we we are fully
functional human beings we're not you
shouldn't be afraid of us and I know
unfortunately with the the incredible
the epidemic of mass shootings and right
away you know they what they talk about
their if anyone should be afraid of
mentally ill people it's us I'm afraid
of myself because I don't know what I'm
capable of doing when times aren't going
well but for me meditation daily
exercise trying to eat clean and
continuing to talk about a rich is the
only way I'm going to stay alive and
that's why I had to do something like
this documentary it's not about me it's
not a vanity project I wish I could have
worn a mask I want to show people that
this is real this this has taken an
incredible toll on my family and my
friends and I've had nothing but support
and it it
breaks my heart that so many people
don't have support and I'm apologize but
I can't believe people die simply
because no one is there or they feel
like no one is there that's the worst
man well obviously you're there and
bipolar rock and roller is there on
Friday May 25th at 9:00 Eastern on
Showtime I want to take a 60-second
break when we come back I want to get
into Mayweather McGregor zones all of
that good stuff
also you got it Mauro Ranallo here on
the Rich Eisen show her back in a minute
[Music]
here on the Rich Eisen show again
bipolar rock and roller premieres on May
25th 90s turn time on Showtime were you
called quite an event Mayweather
McGregor from what you were seeing was
Mayweather rope-a-doping him what do you
think yeah interesting he says that he
you know carried him and and I think
Conor McGregor acquitted himself better
than anyone expected and I don't think
we should take away from that in the
same sense I think Floyd Mayweather is
50 no for a reason one of the greatest
defensive fighters of all time but he's
also a showman and I'm not saying that
he carried him but he he realized
especially with the spectacle that this
event was you know my two worlds
colliding where I think he wanted to
make a show of it but but at the same
time I believe Conor McGregor you know
gave him the best fight that he could
with that amount of limited experience
so I can't say for sure that he carried
him but I I do know that it was way more
entertaining that it probably should
have been many of us expected and and so
congratulations to both of them because
people of course had still had the
bitter taste in their mouth of the Floyd
Mayweather Manny Pacquiao super fight
that took forever to to finally come to
fruition so it's one of those
once-in-a-lifetime spectacles the second
biggest pay-per-view in history
everybody got paid even me I got paid at
that event rich do you think you should
get in the Octagon what do you want to
say I was one of those guys that said
they should never I mean I didn't want
to see the box at first because you
wonder you know there's in our business
and you get this to war with the
separation between entertainment and the
actual purity of the sport and the
ratings and the rankings and whatnot as
we see more and more everything now is
entertainment rich so if it's going to
create a buzz and and and get eyeballs I
I think there is still something to be
said about the the purity of the sport
but I don't know where the the
parameters are anymore so I would think
that Floyd Mayweather wouldn't get
inside the Octagon but man with the
amount of money that is potentially at
stake we live in America my friend
I think modalism I think we can agree
though if he gets in the Octagon it's
not boxing you know he needs to he needs
to if you will submit sure you know sure
sure literally but figuratively he needs
to submit to the to fighting an MMA
fight right and many people believe that
yet it will be a short night for for him
inside the Octagon because you don't
become an expert mixed martial artist
overnight it takes but that's the thing
that even between the two sports
themselves and you find anyone in mixed
martial arts who's done boxing it's
completely different sport and that's
why I've never understood covering both
sports calling both sports
us-against-them
what what I enjoy football and
basketball I enjoy hockey I'd you're not
mixing those what you know what I mean
you know hey what about basketball and
ice that'd be great we call they're
either biggest character you ever met
from from the wrestling Wow
you Nature Boy Ric Flair man that it's
the beginning and end and it was an
honor for me as of course a long time
wrestling fan starting it when I first
came to WWE and he was backstage and and
we ended up at a hotel bar where the
legendary stories begin and I'll never
forget I course honored to be there
wanting to buy the Nature Boy Ric Flair
a drink he legitimately got pissed at me
rich he was like nobody pays when the
nature boys around and sure enough he
took care of everybody and he is a
bonafide legend the
my favorite wrestler of all time you
didn't you didn't stutter I mean there
are so many obviously that iha styles
and John Cena the pleasure of calling
their 2017 WWE match of the Year Royal
Rumble a Daniel Bryan I could go on and
on but when it comes to the
quintessential professional wrestler and
a guy you know who lives the gimmick as
it were its Nature Boy Ric Flair well I
could go on and on about you know
obviously the MMA boxing and wrestling
but a couple of people heard what you
had to say and I want to give them their
say here with you tomorrow let's go to
dusty in Wyoming you're on the Rich
Eisen show with with Mauro Ranallo dusty
what's what's going on dusty you're I
just want to thank y'all coming on I'm a
disabled veteran in Laramie Wyoming here
I PTSD I paid 100% by the government to
stay at home and take care of my kids
and that's some of the best nights and I
can have that he's right talking about
it getting into the open it doesn't fix
it but it helps and it helps everybody
around you help your situation and and
it leads to more support
well Dusty appreciate that and yeah
Dusty thank you and you know what the
way we treat our veterans in this
country is criminal the fact that they
have to go and see what they see and do
what they do for this country for our
freedom and we do not invest resources
into taking care of them physically
mentally and otherwise it's it's
shameful so dusty thank you for your
service and and thank you very much for
your support thank you very much and you
it defecate going to Iraq exactly you
know create these mental problems some
people are born with them some people
get accidents some people are dropped as
a baby you know there are lots of things
that lead to PTSD bipolarism and all
there's there's a lot that we do and
thank you for being on they're giving
away thank you for calling dusty enjoy
the time with your kids John and Miami
your
with Mauro Ranallo here on the Rich
Eisen show John hey thanks I've never
called into a show before I happen to be
stepping out of a business lunch and I
caught the very moving remarks here and
looked up your number online and I'm
thankful for you taking my call I'm more
thankful for you addressing the issue
I've been a professional banker in the
Miami area for about 20 seasons to
highest levels I've been not working for
about two years suffering from high
anxiety nothing quite as cleanly
diagnosed as bipolar a lot of depression
anxiety I turned to drugs and alcohol
groomers have gotten around I cleaned
that up and I'm feeling very
clear-headed and scared to go back to
where I was self-medicating and but I
you know I'm if there is a stigma I'm
trying to be honest with people about
where I'm at and I just think it's
incredibly timely and I really enjoy
hearing to two men talk about it so
openly I think there needs to be forum
for it thank you well thank you and rich
honestly what he's just mentioned as
well and even that the veteran we don't
know what causes it I still don't they
say chemical imbalance they say could be
the environment they say could be your
diet maybe and my family on my mother's
side I know it's there we need to invest
resources we need more money we need
help these people should not be in jail
they should be being treated give the
money that's necessary for research the
rich they tell me more I'll take this
pill it'll make you feel better why well
we don't know but studies have shown I'm
gonna stick with something that has
actually kept me alive and saved my life
and this has a stigma attached to it too
the only reason I'm still here the only
reason I'm working is because of
cannabis rich and I know with the NFL in
it I wish my mom was on cannabis and I'm
not saying that I'm stepping on the
soapbox everyone go get high and stoned
and you know the stigma though that it's
attached with that there is something in
cannabis whether the THC or the CBD that
has proven and I'm living proof that it
not only helps but enhances my quality
of life why would we
not something that is natural give it to
people instead of I was on Allatoona I
had restless leg syndrome
I paced back and forth of my apartment
for literally for hours rich I almost
jumped off the balcony I was on lithium
I put on thirty pounds the side effects
of these chemicals Big Pharma is
literally killing people they're putting
money in their coffers meanwhile
families are putting bodies in coffins
and enough is enough so I'm glad that
people are finally starting to take
notice and especially men rich men need
to start talking more and more about
their mental health
well Morrow come back any time man I'm
willing to miss conversation any time
you want to have it I appreciate your
support
thank you so much shake your hand sir
bipolar rock and roll or check it out
May 25th ninety students a night out
burns on the guy's Hall of Famer loves
you and that's called a fight together
did you not an ESPN we we did
SportsCenter at the Hollifield more good
fight we'll always have a mensch as they
say me and uh he John Saracino right
awesome good to see you good to see you
rich anytime Ranallo again check out his
uh his documentary Friday May 25th on
Showtime the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience